American is the latest climber to die on
Mount Everest Colorado attorney Chris
kulish collapsed on his way down after
reaching the summit he is at least the
11th fatality there this season CTM
national correspondent jury kanou-kun is
here with more on that story so Jericka
what do the experienced climbers say now
about conditions on that mountain well
they say that it's really difficult no
matter how ready you are for this trip
we spoke to someone on the same
expedition as Chris Coolidge who says
the climber was fully prepared for his
own mission to scale the world's tallest
mountain but he was not prepared for
what he saw when he got there too many
people dangerously vying for the same
experience it's the top of the world but
on an icy platform no wider than two
ping pong tables that over 29,000 feet
capturing the moment can get dangerous
that's what made it scary for me is that
there was a large group on the summit at
the time I got there there was a
subgroup that was very rude and unruly
and was basically pushing so that they
could get better pictures of themselves
and I just thought this is not safe but
before you even make it to the top
traffic jams on the final few feet an
area known as the Death Zone at that
altitude there is not enough oxygen for
humans to breathe so vital supplies are
used up while the primers just wait too
many are navigating to smaller space and
dr. doreen says too many of them don't
know what they're doing I was surprised
at how many people were you know above
26,000 feet and had really were
obviously we're either not fit or not
experienced and probably shouldn't have
been there during witnessed firsthand
the deadly combination and I certainly
wasn't prepared to pass dead bodies that
were attached to the safety line it was
very difficult
on May 29th 1953 when Sir Edmund Hillary
became the first climber to reach the
summit its Sherpa Tenzing Norgay it was
global news 66 years almost to the day
scaling the world's tallest mountain has
become an Instagram moment a feat not
just for the best but for almost anyone
with a bucket list and we should add
that dr. doreen told us that despite all
the well-documented problems on the
mountain he does not think that Chris
Coolidge died as a result of the
overcrowding nor was he inexperienced
coolish was extremely fit even at 62 and
was climbing with what he described as
probably the best guide team on the
mountain Anthony still can't get over
the pictures of that line up there
Jericka amazing thank you